a little reject ville nation reject
reject nation that is America these days
Greg Alba here Jean here we're gonna
watch the trailer for the Netflix reboot
a series of unfortunate events Lemony
Snicket's remember that movie Jim Carrey
Count Olaf yeah a movie greatly
underperformed yeah I was a bummer
because I like that movie yeah I like I
do too there's a dark is like 2004 he
meant the same here I think the third
Harry Potter movie came out I just think
it was a little bit a little too early
just a few years too early I feel like
if it came out around now I think more
people probably would have been on board
that book grabbed some traction people
seem to read that series pretty I
remember that movie cost like 130 or 140
million and only made like 200 million
in total oh boy yeah so did not do well
I'm interested to see what Netflix does
with it I like Neil Patrick Harris I did
too I don't I haven't seen this yet but
I've no reason to believe he couldn't do
it yeah this is the meets I think it's
the called the meet count a loft teaser
trailer okay cuz I know there have been
two well let's check out this one
snowman
specifically he was waiting very eager
to get his hands on you something
strange is going on if she had to in his
ankle he's in disguise and he's trying
to take us away you'll never get away
with this
murderer and so far it's completely
escaped capture
you haven't the faintest idea
all right interesting all right
so far the look looks like the movie
yeah I know it's based on a famous book
or famous books well I think those head
illustrations and I think they've
borrowed from those two yeah yeah cuz
like the lighting and everything looks
like yeah this looks exactly like what I
remember the movie you like well I don't
really think there's a reason to change
I thought the production design
especially of that movie was fantastic
oh yeah and it's really dark I love a
good dark children's tale you know cuz
cuz Harry Potter after a certain point
stops being a children's tale and just
becomes an epic and I feel like there is
something still youthful about a series
of unfortunate events at night I kind of
like that this is a show now because you
know it's for sure a show it's not a TV
movie yeah it's at all episodes the
kinds of stories we're telling in TV
show format are broadening out yet still
nothing is necessarily for children but
a dark youth accessible sort of a show
seems like a cool idea and it seems like
they're certainly putting the money up
for that production value that's
interesting when they adapt a book into
a television show because usually when
you start off with it with that it's
like oh this is reminiscent of the book
but then after a while you you run out
of book material the cover and then you
start creating your own so I'm wondering
how long they believe they can get this
going for something tells me Neil
Patrick Harris will give a much darker
interpretation of Count Olaf because Jim
Carrey's Count Olaf was really funny but
a lot of it was just Jim yeah yeah and I
mean I liked him in that role I do
sometimes I struggle with Jim Carrey
because sometimes I'm distracted by its
being Jim Carrey and that role I thought
he kind of struck a a nicer balance for
my taste but I am interested to see what
NPH does with this because it will I
feel like it will be its own character
and also Jim Carrey it's like that's why
I had trouble with the Grinch too is
like you're also Jim Carrey and I feel
like Neil Patrick Harris is great for
this kind of roles like Neil Patrick
Harris I think does a really good job in
dark roles I mean I recently finished a
freak show and he had a few episodes in
there where it was a very dark role it
was you know magician with a fucked-up
past
I feel like Neil Patrick Harris he
doesn't he's nowhere near like Jim
Carrey in general like I said would
count Hall off it was like yeah it's Jim
Carrey though just with a bunch of crazy
but there's like a lot of improvised
moments or you're like this is totally
Jim Carrey yeah yeah and I don't feel
like we're gonna get that I feel like
this time we'll get a very definitive
interpretation of Count Olaf because
Neil Patrick Harris is well he can be uh
you know big personality while he can
really be expression it I really feel
like he's definitely a little bit more
grounded than the likes of Kerry well
and I'm I'm really excited to see him
slip into a character you know with a
different look that's not just you know
him - yeah cuz he's popped up in things
in you know dramas here and there and
and other stuff since How I Met Your
Mother
you know he's always kind of Neil
Patrick Harris and so now he's got the
makeup on he's got the crazy hair I like
at least that one moment where he speaks
you know I like what is what has I guess
accent or yeah it sounds like you know
and I'm excited to see him play a
character again and beyond that the
production design does look really
[ __ ] good like it looks like a movie
it looks like a movie and the quality of
it I could easily if they said like oh
we're remaking this into a film a
feature film if I first saw this and it
was if it was just a minute longer I
would have probably mistaken this to be
a full-length feature film yeah the set
pieces all the designs the coloring the
the lighting of the way it's all shot
this looks like a very appealing show
yeah I do this could be a great fantasy
filled fun time and I feel like this
could be something great for the fans
and it's smart to move this great
concept this huge beloved story into
television format is clearly in film it
didn't do well I mean if you look at the
numbers of a to hunt a little over 200
million and you bring that to show that
those are good numbers yeah that's I can
see from a marketing perspective why
they believe they will work on a TV show
and there's different stuff you can do
it that I don't I don't know as much
about how the money breaks down didn't
it see I'm all about mine yeah totally
out of money it's what makes the world
go round
yeah yeah really for Trump totally make
America something or other
it's make America great again John again
they're jokes what content like well
America is bad we still need to achieve
like certain levels of great it's all
about the economy
yeah God built this world when the world
was built on us nature and the economy
yes now our American lives revolve
around the two most naturalistic forms
of this world primarily the economy
uh-huh yeah something invented by humans
that's what God gave us I believe that
was one of the original commandment says
thou shalt open up a checking account
you know First National Bank of that's
why Jesus was so excited when all those
people were like trading money in the
church he flaked flipped over a table
cuz it was so so exciting oh my god you
guys you're doing it you're doing it
great enough political support aside
subscribe today rejects I get accepted
join us and John is reasons to Jerri on
Instagram and Twitter facebook.com slash
Blum house and the real rejects he's the
social media manager of and